welcome to this video on Plato muneca
why's he still on there he should be
banned actually for for cheating we had
some times okay he doesn't cheat in
every game but he does cheat definitely
in some games and so I hope it's not
that's not one of them okay okay I know
it takes some time yeah I talked to a
friend of mine and he said he checked
his games very very closely and it's a
it's a very clever way of using the
engineer and there but ok anyway it's
may be difficult to bend those guys so
this is a scotch game an opening that I
get quite frequently if it goes f3 now
it doesn't use the engine in this game
and d5 is already great it looks it
looks good anyway to be honest so hmm I
cannot why can I not take you for some
kind of weird tactic with yeah but
should have seven queen of three but I
can definitely take on d4 and play some
kind of d5 I have to be aware of a5
though maybe I can do this this is an
interesting way to play context and then
d5
he's got two bishops but I have a very
good very good structure with them this
play against iqp the knight on D 2 is
passive and I have before as a very good
square for all night so I cannot take
there because of f7 issues so let's go
here
it should be 5 hmm okay maybe I can do
this for Bishop g5 and then Knight f5
this kind of thing
I also definitely don't want those split
pawns there one c6 takes Teague's okay
that's a key Knight c5 Bishop cat5 mmm
okay yeah anyway it's always a retaining
to play against the cheetah and as I
said for some reason is not banned I
don't know why maybe it's difficult and
in this case I have play against the
games against him wait did not cheat and
have played against the games against
him very definitely use an engine they
have been both both cases
okay then he's got 25 hmm
James to take I have the night is
hanging the night is singing
yeah and how to tell if this is a
cheating game or a normal game because I
really played this badly
Jim no thanks it's made only aid yeah
anyway this kind of games are just suck
and I'm going to again complain to the
ICCA they should Bend those [ __ ] it
just just like that iam not sure if what
it was in this case but he has cheated
in games 100% sure we can do a quick
check with them
I mean I have stock fish stock fish also
wants to play a four year so this is
identical and C takes D 5 D next takes
rook see one or two stock fish want to
play rook e1 yeah I mean we don't know
what engineer uses sometimes it should
be six it should be five s also engine
right if a 16 695 yeah this is losing
due to Bishop g5 hard to tell I mean I
just played badly but it's difficult to
play against someone where you know that
he cheats so it's a bit of a bit of a
shame that line is pretty young and
pretty harmless by the way and I have to
improve at one point here Bishop d7 as
given by the Vice stockfish I don't want
to double the pawns ready
okay maybe Bishop e6 is also something
that can be
improved upon what about this is the
symbol maybe for c6 maybe I should do
something like that I think it should be
about equal nothing particularly am bad
happening here for me
yeah okay I'm going to going to report
him again but probably a.m. there are
some problems improving that okay thanks
for watching